بدا اليوم برنامج الرياض الخضراء عماله
تنفيذ تشجير الاحياء السكنيه بدايه من حي
العزيزيه الذي سيشهد زراعه
623,000 شجره وشجره فضلا عن تشجيري احداه
60 مدرسه و78 موقعا لمواقف السيارات واكثر
من 170 كم من الطرق والممرات يستهدف
البرنامج اكثر من 120 حيا سكنيا تشمل
تنفيذ حدائق وتشجير الشوارع الداخليه
وتنفيذ ارصفه مشجره وغيرها
الرياضي انضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الواحد الحميد عبد الواحد حياك الله اذا
هناك الان البدايه الفعليه ربما في
التشجير في بعض المناطق في الرياض ما هي
التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بك خالد نعم نحن الان في حي
العزيزيه حيث
ينتصف هذا الحي حديقه كبيره من المقرر
انشاؤها وبدات بالفعل طبعا فيما يتعلق
بهذا الحديقه بدات بالفعل عمليات انشاء
الحديقه من ناحيه ممرات وكذلك من ناحيه
الزراعه حتى في منتصف هذه الحديثه نجد هذا
المعرض الذي
يشرح للسكان همم ماذا سوف يحتوي مشروع
رياض الخضراء وتحديدا الخطه المقرر البدء
بها فيما يتعلق بحي العزيزيه نتحدث اكثر
عن طبعا كل هذه التفاصيل من خلال
المعلومات الظاهره في هذا المعرض هناك همم
يعني همم المعلومات التي يستقبل بها
العارضون السكان
ليشرحون لهم ماذا سوف يتم العمل عليه في
حي العزيزيه هذا المعرض يستمر حتى سبعه
يناير طبعا واليوم هو اول يوم نتحدث عن
اكثر من همم 176 كيلو متر من الطرق
والممرات اضافه الى ان انواع الاشجار
والشجيرات التي تم اختيارها طبعا تتم
زراعتها السوائل في العزيزيه او في احياء
الرياض ال120 هذه الاشجار والشجيرات يعني
تبتسم بانها لا تحتاج الكثير من الماء
ومناسبه كثيرا للبيئه المحليه خالد
سال مين في رياض الخضراء لماذا اختاروا حي
العزيزيه لاقامه هذا المعرض فاجابونا بان
حي العزيزيه اولا يكتظ بالسكان هذه نقطه
ونقطه الاخرى ان حي العزيزيه كذلك في
العديد من المصانع بالتالي من اكثر
الاحياء احتياجا
للزراعه الاشجار والشجيرات يعني همم كنا
قد سالنا كم عدد الحدائق
المقرر زراعتها هنا في حي العزيزيه
وانشائها بشكل همم يعني همم متوزع في هذا
الحي نتحدث عن اكثر من 50 حديقه نتحدث
كذلك عن طبعا كل المرافق الاخرى التي يتم
العمل على تشجيرها من خلال همم بهذا
المشروع همم يعني نشاهد في في الاسفل هذه
هي الخريطه التي يتم من خلالها الشرح هي
السكان همم حول همم الاماكن التي سوف يتم
الزراعه بها حي العزيزيه خالد يحتوي يعني
اليوم يحتوي 10,000 شجره تقريبا من مقرر
ان تصل الى اكثر من
600,000
شجره وشجيره همم يعني هذه هي الخطه
المستقبليه فيما يتعلق بحي العزيزيه حتى
الان المعرض يستقبل السكان المحليين من
مختلف الاطياف هنا في حي العزيزيه لي يشرح
لهم هذه الخطه وماذا سوف يتم العمل عليه
في هذا الحي شكرا عبد الواحد يعطيك
العافيه